they had thought their plight couldn't
get more serious but it appears they
were wrong these migrants say they're
stranded on this beach on tunisia's side
of its border with Libya
we're forced to drink sea water yet we
shouldn't drink it and they say the
security forces mistreated them before
leaving them here this video has been
filmed by one of the migrants on his
phone here he's shouting at border
guards
blah blah
we don't know where to go we don't eat
anything
look at this baby he's hardly eaten
and look at this woman
the migrants had been moved from
tunisia's second City's facts in a
Security operation mounted after a
Tunisian man was killed allegedly by
migrants tensions have been increasing
sub-Saharan African migrants say
hundreds of them have been rounded up
for deportation but Libya was refusing
to let them in svax is on tunisia's
eastern coast and a main departure point
for migrants and refugees trying to
cross the Mediterranean in boats Bound
for Italy
hostility towards the sub-Saharan
Africans has increased following remarks
by tunisia's President kais Saeed
accusing them of criminality he ordered
a Crackdown
in fact many tunisians say the migrants
should go home
Tunisia and the tunisians have enough
troubles now we are flooded with these
migrants coming from the sea or the
desert the state authorities should do
something
for now their stalemate over the
migrants Tunisia wants them out and
Libya refuses to let them in they've
been abandoned and there's no doubt
about the urgency of getting them food
water and shelter Andrew Simmons Al
Jazeera